GREG GUTFELD.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PREPARE TO GET YOUR MIND BLOWN
WITH EYE-POPPING TESTIMONY.
>> WHAT I CAN DO HERE FOR YOU
HERE TODAY IS TELL YOU WHAT I
HEARD FROM PEOPLE.
>> WHERE IS THE IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE IN THAT CALL.
ARE EITHER OF YOU HERE TO ASSERT
THERE WAS AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE
AND THAT CALL?
SHOUT IT OUT.
ANYONE?
>> Greg: CONGRATS, ADAM
SCHIFF.
YOU FOUND SOMETHING THAT MADE
THE MUELLER HEARING LOOK SEXY.
A BLOATED SPECTACLE DESIGNED TO
TURN A PHONE CALL INTO A CRIME.
IF ONLY WE COULD SEE THIS COMIN
COMING.
>> A BIG CALL TO IMPEACHMENT.
>> THAT TWEET IS ALSO ENOUGH TO
IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> IMPEACH 45!
>> THE CALL FOR THE IMPEACHMENT
OF THE PRESIDENT.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS DONE THINGS
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT IS A REAL
POSSIBILITY.
>> WE ARE GOING TO GO IN THERE
AND [BLEEP].
>> Greg: I GUESS THEY GOT THE
SAME EMAIL FROM JEFF ZUCKER.
BRIGGS US TO THIS
SHOW TRIAL ABOUT THE NEXT WORST
THING EVER THAT NEVER HAPPENS.
THIS IS NEVER ABOUT WHAT TRUMP
HAS DONE BUT WHAT HE COULD DO.
THIS WHOLE THING IS A CRAPPY
HORROR MOVIE SCRIPTED BY THE
DEMS WITH ADAM SCHIFF PLAYING
THE BUG EYED ZOMBIES.
THIS IS WORSE THAN A HORROR
FILM.
IT'S PORNOGRAPHY FOR DEMOCRATS.
REMEMBER THE SAFE WORD?
>> THAT SOUND LIKE A QUID PRO
QUO DIRECTED BY THE PRESIDENT.
>> THAT IS IN FACT A QUID PRO
QUO.
>> THERE WAS IN FACT A QUID PRO
>> BE VERY CLEAR, QUID PRO QUO.
>> THAT IS A QUID PRO QUO!
>> Greg: THAT'S LEVERAGE AND
USING IT ON BEHALF OF YOUR
COUNTRY IS B FIVES JOB
ESPECIALLY WHEN HE COULDN'T
TRUST ANYONE ELSE TO DO IT.
WE HEARD PEOPLE TRYING TO STOP
HIM.
HOW COULD WE HAVE A PRESIDENT A
CANDIDATE WHOSE SON IS BEHOLDEN
TO UKRAINE AND CHINA.
IF HE DIDN'T INVEST GET THAT,
THAT'S IMPEACHABLE.
TRUMP BROKE NO LAWS BUT HE MAY
BREAK THE RULES A BIT BECAUSE HE
HAS TO BECAUSE THE MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS WRITE THE RULEBOOK.
WHICH IS WHY THIS IMPEACHMENT
SPECTACLE IS JUST A REPEAT OF
THE COLLISION SPECTACLE.
A MYSTERIOUS SOURCE TRIGGERS A
MASSIVE INVESTIGATION THAT THEN
GOES NOWHERE.
WE'VE SEEN IT.
WE'VE DONE IT.
WE PAID FOR IT.
MY ADVICE?
SKIP IT AND SHOW UP NEXT
NOVEMBER AND GIVE THESE CLOWNS A
HEARING THEY'LL NEVER FORGET.
I WANT TO PLAY THIS, IT'S SCHIFF
TALKING ABOUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
WITH JIM JORDAN.
WHAT'S ENTERTAINING, KATIE?
>> YOU ARE THE ONLY MEMBER WHO
KNOWS WHO THE INDIVIDUAL IS AND
YOUR STAFF IS THE ONLY STAFF OF
ANY MEMBER OF CONGRESS TO TALK
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL APPEARED
WE'D LIKE THAT OPPORTUNITY.
WHEN WOULD THAT HAPPEN WITH THIS
PROCEEDING TODAY?
>> AS THE GENTLEMAN KNOWS,
THAT'S A FALSE STATEMENT THAT I
DO NOT KNOW THE IDENTITY OF THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER AND I'M MAKING
SURE THE IDENTITY IS PROTECTED.
>> Greg: HE DOESN'T KNOW,
KATIE.
HE DOESN'T KNOW!
>> Katie: THIS IS THE SECOND
TIME HE'S CHANGED HIS STORY
KNOWING FOR THE PERSON IS.
HE RECEIVED A COMPLAINT ON
AUGUST 12TH ABOUT WHAT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WAS ALLEGING.
HIS STAFF TOOK IT, DIDN'T SHARE
IT WITH HIS FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS UNTIL THE END OF SAID
OF SEPTEMBER.
HE'S LYING.
HE KNOWS EXACTLY WHO THE PERSON
IS BUT LET'S TAKE HIM AT HIS
WORD FOR ONES.
IF HE SAYS --
>> Dana: YOU JUST SAID HE'S
LYING.
>> Katie: IF WE ARE GOING TO
LISTEN TO ADAM SCHIFF AND
BELIEVE WHAT HE SAID IS TRUE,
HIS STAFF ARE THE ONES WHO HAVE
MET THIS PERSON, UNELECTED
STAFFERS WHO ARE NOW RUNNING THE
SHOW IMPEACHMENT BASED ON A
CLAIM MADE THAT THEY ARE ARGUING
SHOULD BE USED TO TAKE THE
PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES OUT
OF OFFICE.
IF ADAM SCHIFF HASN'T TALKED TO
THIS PERSON, DOESN'T KNOW THEM,
HASN'T MET WITH THEM, HAS
INVITED THEM TO MAKE SURE THEY
ARE LEGITIMATE AND THEIR CLAIMS
ARE LEGITIMATE, THAN THE STAFF
IS DOING IT FOR HIM AND THERE
SHOULD BE A LITTLE MORE
SCRUTINY.
>> Juan: WAIT A SECOND, WHAT
ABOUT THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE INSPECTOR GENERAL
SAYING THIS IS A LEGITIMATE
ISSUE, THIS WHISTLE-BLOWER
COMPLAINT SHOULD BE FORWARDED
EVEN AFTER THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT -- THAT'S NOT THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Katie: SO WHY DIDN'T ADAM
SCHIFF SHARE WITH THE REST OF
HIS COMMITTEE MEMBERS?
BEFORE GIVING IT TO THE REST OF
THE COMMITTEE?
>> Juan: WHAT I'M SAYING TO
YOU IS FIRST OF ALL THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT HAS
BEEN CONFIRMED BY EVERYBODY
INCLUDING THE TWO PEOPLE WHO
WERE THERE TODAY.
>> Greg: HEARSAY.
>> Juan: IT'S NOT HEARSAY.
YOU ARE SAYING THIS WAS BORING.
I DO NOT THINK IT WAS BORING.
I THINK, IN FACT, IF THIS WAS SO
BORING, WHY HAVE WE SEEN THAT
TREMENDOUS MOVEMENT IN THE POLL
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS?
>> Greg: THE MEDIA IS 94%
ANTI-TRUMP --
BE TO KNOW, IT'S NOT!
>> Greg: YOU BEEN TALKING ALL
DAY!
JESSE AND KATIE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS TOPIC.
YOU'VE BEEN ON TV FOR SIX HOURS.
>> Juan: IS THAT RIGHT?
>> Jesse: I'M GOING TO LOOK AT
IT OBJECTIVELY, GREG, LIKE I
USUALLY DO.
PUT MY ANALYST HAT ON.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS DID THE
BEST THEY COULD DO TODAY BUT IT
WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH.
IT WAS NOT A PERSUASIVE HEARING.
IT WAS DENSE.
GRIPING BY NO-NAME DIPLOMATS.
I RESPECT THEIR SERVICE.
THEY CARE A LOT FOR THE COUNTRY
FOR THEY WANT TO FIGHT OFF
RUSSIAN AGGRESSION.
TO ME, IT LOOKED LIKE THEY WERE
COMPLAINING ABOUT A TURF WAR
OVER POLICY AND PERSONNEL, AND
WERE UPSET THAT RUDY WAS
STEPPING ON THEIR TOES.
THIS WAS A HEARSAY READING.
THEY HAVE NEVER MET
DONALD TRUMP, THEY WERE NOT ON
THE CALL AND NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE AID PACKAGE.
THIS HAD NONE OF THE INTENSITY
OF THE KAVANAUGH HEARING.
NONE OF THE INTENSITY OF THE
MUELLER HEARING WHERE I
REMEMBER, YOU REMEMBER BOTH OF
THOSE HEARINGS WERE PEOPLE AT
WORK WOULD STOP EVERYTHING AND
TURN ON THE TV, AND YOU COULD
HEAR A PIN DROP.
THIS WAS NOT THAT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I THOUGHT
THE REPUBLICAN CROSS WAS A
STRONG, FOR THE MOST PART, AND
THE REPUBLICAN BASE WILL NOT
CRACK, AND THE REPUBLICANS IN
THE SENATE WILL NOT VOTE TO
CONVICT, AND THIS WHOLE
CHARADE -- THIS IS THE HIGH
WATER MARK.
THIS WILL ALL FADE AS WE GO
HEARING AFTER HEARING AFTER
HEARING.
>> Greg: YOU CAN GO AHEAD NOW.
I WANTED TO GET HIM IN.
>> Juan: NO, I LOVE WISHFUL
THINKING.
THE MARCHING ORDERS FROM THE
REPUBLICAN RANK -- I'LL TELL YOU
STRAIGHT NEWS.
NO WAY IS TO GO FROM 20%
SUPPORTING IMPEACHMENT --
>> Jesse: YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT POLLS.
>> Juan: IT'S GONE TO THE
POINT WHERE HALF OF AMERICA
THINKS HE SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
>> Greg: 94% OF THE MEDIA.
>> Juan: THAT'S NOT TRUE.
TO PICK UP ON YOUR POINT, I
THINK THESE TWO WITNESSES CAME
ACROSS AS INCREDIBLY CREDIBLE.
>> Dana: OKAY.
>> Juan: WEST POINT GRADUATES,
HIS WHOLE FAMILY, CAREER
DEDICATED TO SERVING THE COUNTR
COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: I'M GLAD YOU
MENTIONED THAT BECAUSE I'D
ACTUALLY WANT TO SAY SOME OF THE
THINGS THESE GENTLEMEN TESTIFIED
TO UNDER OATH.
OKAY?
THESE ARE THE DEMOCRATS' STAR
WITNESS, NOT A WITNESS TO
ANYTHING.
TESTIFIED, TAYLOR: TAYLOR MET
WITH UKRAINE PRESIDENT THE DAY
AFTER THIS PERFECT PHONE CALL
AND THE UKRAINE PRESIDENT TOLD
HIM, THE WITNESS FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, HE HAD NO COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE CALL, IT WAS A GREAT
CALL, THERE WERE NO CONCERNS.
THEN TAYLOR, THE DEMOCRATS 'STAR
WITNESS, MET THREE TIMES AFTER
THAT WITH UKRAINE PRESIDENT AND
DID NO TIME THE UKRAINE
PRESIDENT OR ANYBODY BRING UP
ANY LEAKAGE BETWEEN THE AID IN
THE INVESTIGATION.
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
ALSO, TAYLOR TESTIFIED THAT
UKRAINE DIDN'T EVEN THOUGH THE
AIDE WAS DELAYED COME AS NO QUID
PRO QUO.
JUST FOR A LITTLE CHERRY ON TOP,
ONE WILLIAM ZELNICK, TAYLOR, THE
DEMOCRATS' STAR WITNESS, SAID IT
WAS BETTER THAN THE OBAMA
POLICY.
>> Dana: WHAT DO YOU WANT ME
TO CALL DELMA TALK ABOUT?
>> MR. SONDLAND CALLED
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND TOLD HIM
ABOUT HIS MEETINGS BE THE MEMBER
OF MY STAFF COULD HEAR
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON THE PHONE
ASKING AMBASSADORS SONDLAND
ABOUT THE INVESTIGATIONS.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS SPEAKING
LOUD ENOUGH FOR YOUR STAFF
MEMBER TO OVERHEAR THIS?
>> HE WAS.
>> Greg: THIS IS THIRD PERSON
REMOVE NOW FROM THE STAFF MEMBER
WHO OVERHEARD IT.
>> Dana: PEOPLE ONLY SEIZED ON
IT BECAUSE TAYLOR DID NOT HAVE
THIS IN HIS ORIGINAL DEPOSITION.
A STAFFER OF HIS SAID, I NEED TO
TELL YOU ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I
DIDN'T TELL YOU BEFOREHAND SO
MUCH LIKE ABBASID OR SONDLAND,
HE SAID I NEED TO AMEND AND MAKE
SURE I HAVE EVERYTHING, I DO NOT
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT THEY
ARE NO NAME.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO DO THIS.
THEY WEREN'T THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
I THINK WHEN RATLIFF ASKED THEM
ARGUE FOR IMPEACHMENT CLICK
CLICK WE DIDN'T WANT TO BE HERE
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WE WERE HERE AS WITNESSES, THEY
WERE ASKED ARE YOU AGAINST
TRUMP.
SAYS, I'M NOT A NONPARTISAN
GUY -- HE SAID, NO, SIR, TO THE
QUESTION OF NEVER TRUMPER.
THE REPUBLICANS DID A GOOD JOB
ON CROSS-EXAMINATION.
I THINK THE PASSION GOT AHEAD OF
THEM, IT WAS A LITTLE
OFF-PUTTING BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
NEED TO DO THAT, COME ON SO
HEAVY.
BUT THEIR POINT ABOUT IT BEING
SECONDHAND OR THIRDHAND, THAT
WILL CHANGE NEXT WEEK.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS NOT GOING
TO HAPPEN FOR ONE DAY.
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN THE NEXT
SEVERAL DAYS AND NEXT WEDNESDAY
AMBASSADOR SONDLAND, THE
EXPECTATIONS FOR HIM WILL BE